[Musica]
vi siete mai chiesti Qual è stata la
prima volta che avete visto tagliare un
filo è un gesto così banale che spesso
non gli diamo significato oggi vi vorrei
parlare di un filo speciale di un filo
che non si può vedere né toccare Ma è un
filo così importante che è presente con
noi fin dal primo istante è il cordone
ombelicale che non solo è un canale di
nutrimento ma rappresenta il primo
legame invisibile che si crea con la
nostra storia e se ci pensate bene con
la nostra stessa vita Ecco questo filo
così importante quando nasciamo viene
tagliato E questa pratica così comune a
cui la maggior parte di noi non dà peso
in realtà ci separa dall'unica cosa che
conosciamo la mamma e ci divide e ci
distacca da un ambiente sicuro E
protetto in cui non eravamo mai soli per
la prima volta sperimentiamo nella
nostra vita il senso di di separazione e
la paura è nata di morire che ci spinge
a cercare L'unica cosa che conosciamo la
nostra mamma il neonato infatti nasce
con l'aspettativa
istintiva che qualcuno si prenda cura di
lui per la sua
sopravvivenza durante i nove mesi della
gravidanza il neonato vive in costante
connessione con la madre in una bolla
ovattata dove il battito del cuore
scandisce le sue giornate attraverso di
lei comincia a scoprire il mondo e
percepisce le prime emozioni tutto
bellissimo però Però ad un certo punto
che cosa succede che veniamo che veniamo
separati dall'unica cosa che conosciamo
e passiamo ai primi mesi della nostra
vita nella costante ricerca della
connessione perduta come se non bastasse
ci si è messa pure l'evoluzione della
specie umana e così cosa è successo che
alla fine degli anni 40 Oltre al fatto
che molte donne iniziarono a andare a
lavorare si diffusero nuove teorie
educative secondo le quali per per
crescere adulti sani ed autonomi
bisognasse staccarli precocemente dalle
loro madri tenerli in braccio il meno
possibile e lasciarli piangere per
fargli sviluppare una maggiore capacità
polmonare la teoria del vizio di cui
almeno tutti Credo avrete sentito
parlare una vol almeno una volta nella
vostra vita da qualche parente ossia che
i bambini in braccio Si viziano è
partita da qui in realtà sapete che cosa
succede quando noi lasciamo un neonato a
piangere per ore per sviluppare la sua
capacità
polmonare capisce Per la prima volta che
è solo e che nessuno è disposto a
prendersi cura di lui e si arrende con
questa frase Forse vi ha scioccato Ma
probabilmente è quello che potrebbe
essere successo ad alcuni di voi Per
fortuna nel
1960 John bby medico e psicanalista
britannico
formulò la prima teoria su
l'attaccamento fu il primo a capire
l'importanza del contatto tra madre e
bambino egli studiò il fatto che
l'evoluzione della personalità del
bambino dipendeva dallo stile di
attaccamento che si creava tra madre e
figlio nei primi tre anni di vita e non
solo capì che quanto più la mamma
riusciva a rispondere al bisogno del
contatto del bambino tanto più questo
bambino cresceva come adulto sicuro e
autonomo nell'esplorare il mondo e
questo stile di di attaccamento non
solo creava il legame con la madre ma in
realtà andava ad influire su tutte le
relazioni future di questo bambino anche
da adulto John bby fu il primo a capire
che l'amore non è un vizio di fatto
andando a sfatare tutte le teorie
psicologiche e pedagogiche del tempo fu
pioniere di una nuova corrente di
pensiero che ancora oggi trova riscontro
in tantissimi
studi ora avete capito perché il titolo
del mio speech è perché siamo adulti
fuori trama siamo fuori trama non solo
perché c'è stato tagliato il primo filo
alla nascita ma anche perché quel
bisogno di contatto di connessione che
altro non è che la ricerca di ricucire
quel filo spezzato che ci è stato
tagliato alla nascita
probabilmente inconsciamente è stato
ignorato dai nostri genitori non esiste
Infatti il manuale del genitore perfetto
e quello che succede spesso è che i
nostri genitori soprattutto quando sono
le prese con il primo figlio non sanno
cosa fare e si affidano a consigli
esterni senza seguire il proprio
istinto sapete come faccio a sapere
tutte queste cose Probabilmente
penserete che ho studiato psicologia o
pedagogia In realtà ho una laurea in
Economia che non c'entra proprio nulla
ma la vita mi ha portato a sperimentare
sulla mia pelle questo senso di
separazione di cui vi ho parlato prima
15 anni fa sono diventata mamma per la
prima volta mio figlio nato prematuro
per un problema di salute è stato
allontanato da me per i primi due mesi
di vita e quel senso di separazione di
cui vi ho parlato all'inizio non solo
l'ha provato lui ma anche io io il
nostro il nostro filo è stato tagliato
molto precocemente e velocemente e
subito dopo altri fili sono arrivati a
separarci quelli della terapia intensiva
che ci separavano e che mi impedivano di
prenderlo in
braccio solo quando attraverso la
marsupio Terapia ritornavo ad essere una
cosa sola i monitor di mio figlio
smettevano di suonare e tutti i
parametri si
stabilizzava sapete che essere
abbracciati fa produrre al nostro
cervello una serie di ormoni che
migliorano l'umore riducono l'ansia e
aumentano l'autostima Ecco perché quando
tenevo mio figlio in braccio stavo così
bene il contatto era terapeutico per
entrambi Ma allora non lo sapevo io
seguivo solo il mio istinto e quando ero
in terapia intensiva appoggiavo mio
figlio addosso a me e prendevo un
lenzuolo per legarlo attorno al mio
corpo
siccome sono testarda e per capire le
cose Devo sperimentarle per bene nel
2013 sono diventata mamma per la seconda
volta mia figlia voleva stare sempre in
braccio perché soffriva di reflusso sono
passata dal niente al troppo e vi posso
assicurare che anche questa volta non è
stato
facile Quando è nata mia figlia mi è
stata regalata una fascia una di quelle
per portare i bambini ho iniziato ad
usarla ogni giorno mia figlia dormiva
beatamente e le giornate scorrevano
molto più
veloci Era come se io avessi qualcuno in
casa che mi aiutasse ogni giorno quando
ho capito quanto mi era stato utile
questa pratica ossia la pratica del Baby
wiring che è quella di portare i bambini
addosso il proprio corpo con una fascia
o d' un marsupio ho deciso di iniziare a
studiarla e e divulg la perché volevo
che altri genitori conoscessero questo
strumento di aiuto che aveva davvero
rivoluzionato la vita nel mio postpartum
così ho deciso di iniziare a a creare
degli incontri informativi gratuiti a
tema Baby wearing e ho creato una
community su Facebook dove l'anno
successivo ed erano entrati più di 5000
genitori dopo un anno avevo venduto più
di 3000 fasce in tutto il mondo
prodotte e disegnate da me e organizzavo
il primo raduno della mia community dove
arrivarono più di 300 persone da tutta
Italia il messaggio che mi stava dando
la vita mi era molto chiaro e così nel
2017 ho deciso di studiare per diventare
una consulente del Baby wearing e ho
disegnato la prima giacca per portare
che di fatto è diventato il primo
prodotto Where
me nessuno voleva produr mii questa
giacca nessuno C ci credeva tranne me ma
anche questa volta altri fili si sono
arrivati in aiuto quelli delle fasce che
avevo venduto le mamme della mia
community che avevano creato un gr una
grande connessione tra tutti i membri ma
soprattutto un forte senso di fiducia
così ho raccolto Grazie a loro i primi
100 ordini e sono partita nel 2018 ho
fondato la mia startup innovativa di cui
oggi sono la Sio depositando negli anni
sette brevetti e
incontrando più di 5000 famiglie a cui
ho insegnato a portare fisicamente e
virtualmente oggi la community è
cresciuta tantissimo amo non vizio è
diventato il nostro hashtag ufficiale e
lo so che un passo alla volta riusciremo
a sfatare Questa teoria del
Vizio l'anno scorso la nostra startup è
stata incubata come startup con impatto
sociale non solo per l'aiuto che diamo
ai genitori e per l'ecosostenibilità dei
nostri prodotti ma anche per il nostro
modello lavorativo quando ho costruito W
me infatti ho cercato di creare
un'azienda a misura di persona e in
particolare A Misura Di Mamma non
sarebbe stato coerente per me costruire
un'azienda che tenesse lontane le mamme
dai loro bambini e così ho scelto di
chiudere alle 16 di concedere contratti
part-time flessibili e lo smart Working
per dare la possibilità alle mie
collaboratrici di conciliare la vita
lavorativa con quella
personale ma riguardando la mia storia
mi sono posta spesso una
domanda Che cosa di strano il dolore
quando ci siamo dentro ci sembra di non
vedere alto e sembra che quel nero entri
come un ordito in tutte le trame della
nostra vita
sono stata a volta lungo da quell'
ordito nero e poi ad un certo punto l'ho
abbracciato profondamente come solo noi
possiamo abbracciare noi stessi e alla
fine di quel buio ho iniziato a vedere
una luce che è stata quella che mi ha
indicato la strada per uscirne fuori Se
penso alla me di 15 anni fa oltre ad
essere felice Sono Sorpresa perché oggi
sono diventata la persona di cui avrei
avuto bisogno
allora non ho fatto tutto da sola le
persone che mi sono state accanto le
famiglie che ho accompagnato in questi
anni mi hanno aiutato a trasformare quel
dolore in tutto quello che vi ho
raccontato oggi e adesso dopo 15 anni
posso dirvi che ho compreso che la vita
è perfetta anche quando va fuori
[Applauso]
[Musica]
trama
adesso prima di salutarci vi chiedo di
fare una cosa prendete la mano della
persona che avete a
fianco e proviamo a
riconnetterci così Costruiamo una nuova
trama e andiamo a a ricucire quel filo
che abbiamo spezzato
Come vi sentite è bellissimo vedervi da
qui tutti connessi
[Applauso]
Grazie